it's our halloween episode so i have
asked everyone to come
wearing costumes and join with their
audio ready to go
i'm excited if it wasn't obvious um i'm
troy baker
well-known video game voice actor oh
that's that's okay i see what you did
that's very clever
is it i'm waiting for mike oh there he
is
there he is oh my god
mike that just looks like an instagram
filter what the hell
look at his background all right you
guys ready
yeah yeah troy lana
i'll have you know i'm gonna i'm gonna
put a lot of hair in this coffee
look at that i love what did you do
which of us i just put makeup on my face
and wore it backwards cap
i get i when do i ever do a backwards
cap though it was like three weeks ago
and you weren't playing it was dodges i
did intentionally go back
to dodgers by the way that was maybe
that's why they won
the world series for the first time in
32 years
um mike i can't help but notice that you
haven't said anything
uh it's maybe it's a choice
i feel like a disney character i feel
like i should just wave
oh my gosh can we say disney
incredible this is this is i it needs to
be stated
i didn't do your facial hair right i
don't either actually it's just that you
have more this week i think it's just
grown in a bit
i like that alana you and i had the
similar instinct
to i shed up mike bithell and then mike
but i'm the
michael's that's the key here i just all
i have though is the
argyle light the void hat though that
was the closest i could get to an actual
troy hat
so i still have the cowboy hat there
yeah but that's less authentic to your
actual style than this it is
this is this is i mean yeah exactly
and i also recognize this is curlier
than normal hair
sometimes i like to comb my hair it just
takes a long time so you look like me
at uh e3 what the the thing that i feel
that's what i'm specifically cosplaying
is alana
alana got the most uh authentic thing
about me is not the hat
and not the the weird facial hair but
the plunging neckline like
i thought about also adding a scarf just
because i feel like that would be a
thing that you would oh
i forgot to show you i have one more
important part of this costume i got to
say the facial hair
is very hell yeah girl i like that
they're
i like that they're sensors they are
really dirty socks
yeah it's this is very nsfw i would
never
i would never be and there go the
comments that's the comments
they're you be socks i was like i should
wear the socks i love that of all the
people mike bithell and i are the most
wholesome okay here's the bacon
is this unwholesome the the
yeah what drives me the most crazy about
your background alana is that i wish
people who were just
listening to this could see it it's
driving me crazy that there is an
errant piece of sound insulation just
haphazardly placed on the couch oh there
is two you're right
look how much look how much different
like by the way that's like a before and
after shot that's like
yours is like i just moved in and this
is like all right i got some [ __ ]
figured out
yeah it's mad different so if you don't
know
by the way traveler is super
i you did not i got five minutes warning
that we're gonna do this
and austin looks like it he got the same
how dare you i just i whip this together
this is just stuff i'd like right now
this is what i'm gonna do anyway i never
twice in my life if i dressed up for
halloween
twice traveler is super into curious
george right now
so if you don't know what this is i am
clearly
yellow safari man
oh you made him look much better but
look at this i look how
i mean come on nice wow
yours isn't blurred i'll point out as
well yeah i didn't try to censor it
here's the saddest slashed coolest part
i had these these are like
real half chaps i haven't been on a
horse in a year
but these are mine i've not that long
ago you said it like it was forever ago
and a year is not that long for a person
to have ridden a horse in it
is that well i mean like i don't know
actually it may have been longer
maybe longer more than a year without
being on horseback
i can't believe it and it's don't even
get me started on the yacht
my god um when was the last time that i
had pei
almost oysters hi everyone welcome to
play watch listen we are wearing
costumes so if you're listening to the
audio version i'm just going to say it
this episode you should probably go look
at the video
you probably should the video man mike
bithell
you're both charming and terrified it
the hands
are a bit much hang on i need to there's
something i really need to do here
hands are always a bit do you like my
color scheme though like
i want a little creepy nailed it austin
got
cozy i got i got some candles i was
actually gonna line them up right in
front of me so that i just had sort of
candlelight but i had no
i basically would have had to put them
on my computer and was like
make it go like like spooky man the
yellow hat
yeah exactly that's kind of what i was i
turned off
half the lights in here that's that's
that was i i i dig it you look
you actually look less ghostly
ironically
i can't believe mike bethel's background
is that of an englishman and not of an
american
i didn't know that people in the uk did
halloween like we don't care about it in
australia it's not much of a thing
but you've got a minute it's all dead is
not a thing in the uk
no i'm saying it's not in australia i
guess it is nothing else
nothing but spiders and snakes is is
anything else
you know year round so we don't need to
worry about it um i guess i didn't do
introductions yeah you did that's troy
baker
nope that's austin wintery that's mike
bithell
and i'm troy no i'm a tornado i'm i'm
troy lana bithell
yes okay oh because of the shirt
it's a bit old shirt i just uh come on
oh [ __ ] i knew it i get it i didn't i
didn't realize that
wow so i thought we would talk about
spooky stuff this episode because
naturally it's halloween in two days
which is why this has happened
um so that's a lot of stuff today
this is yeah this is just this just
wednesday yes
this is how we're doing the show from
now on i guess i actually have to take
the wig
off for purposes of the show most of the
time because i just
you know right this is your writing wig
or whatever
mine does not i'm sorry about that i was
gonna ask first
um is traveler like super excited to see
you in this costume i
i don't know i'm actually a little there
they every wednesday
he and pam go down ventura and there's
two places that they go to there's um
an outdoor bakery that called
josephine's that they get
um traveling it's a pink donut it has
like a bite but he loves the pink donut
um and then they go to this fish market
simpson
um and we get fish cause we do pokeballs
on wednesday super boring people but
whatever
so they're having their um time delay
between the donut
and the pokey well like snack and dinner
so like we'll do several hours he's not
doing it back to back
okay i was gonna say because that sounds
like an awful pairing and so yeah it's
like
and he throws up every wednesdays
he hates it incidentally i don't know
where the connection is
um so anyway they they have like their
mama dude
uh monkey mama monkey date day whatever
it doesn't matter so um i'm hoping that
they
get back before oh he hasn't seen
you no he hasn't seen me in this yet i
put this on literally so they're they're
gone
and they're they're gonna get back maybe
like 30 45 minutes and hopefully we're
still going
because i'm almost wondering if if he'll
like be terrified like i'm afraid he'll
be like and he'll never be able to watch
curious george again
i don't know yeah he'll be like laugh at
me he'll probably laugh at me
when i was growing up my dad had one of
those tom selleck mustaches
and one day he just impulsively shaved
it ebay
and uh yes exactly that's before ebay
and this was just straight at sotheby's
and um
now he uh he he just decided he didn't
like it one day after like
30 years of having this and so he just
shaved off and i was like
seven and i just rejected it i was like
i
like i like cried and was basically like
i don't know who you are but you're dead
were you like luke
um so i was gonna uh ask you guys the
question of
like very broadly we could talk about
everything if
you can't give me a sentence i was gonna
ask one but it won't happen um what do
you think makes good horror
literally what makes good horror is it
is it suspense
is it climaxes is it violence oh don't
give up
don't give up mike before giving up it's
too hard you still look very
if you had taken that off and you were
like super clean-shaven or something
below that would have been a double
or made up completely ashes
i like what alfred hitchcock said uh
well there's two two quotes that i love
about horror even though i'm not a big
fan of forest i'll probably say this and
then bow out but
two quotes that i love about horror
number one alfred hitchcock said that a
uh a villain must be empathetic you must
um like norman bates you feel sorry for
norman bates interesting
that's what makes him truly really just
like scary
um and then secondly harryhausen said
that
the most frightening beast is one you
can imagine in repose
so it to me it's not just all this the
jump scares it's the
very intelligent it's the methodical
it's the jason walk
it's that's the most terrifying thing
about him is the confidence with which
he walks it doesn't matter where you run
where you hide he can stalk you and find
you
so the the maniacal and stuff i was
terrified of demonic stuff like
like slasher stuff didn't get to me but
it was the
way that i was raised um or like the
omen
it was more now owen's not a scary movie
to me um
neither is rosemary's baby it's just
weird maybe that's of of a time
um but to me it was it was more of like
anything possession
anything dealing with um demons anything
spiritual
quote spiritual warfare because i grew
up in a time in the 90s where this guy
frank pereira wrote a book called
this present darkness and it [ __ ] me
up
um and that was like the only christian
horror book that you could
just stupid i've never been scared of a
book and i've always wanted to find a
book that would scare me
like i've never oh man the necronomicon
i should necronomicon's a good one i
should probably look into it a little
bit further but i i
feel like with video games specifically
so survival horror is my favorite genre
of video game i love the survival horror
i like being scared
and i think the thing that i find to be
the most important for me
um for a lot of reasons is the moment of
safety
so silent hill pt for example uh say
you you feel safe whenever you're at the
door at the very end of the hallway
because you're not going to be attacked
as that loop starts over again
so as you're walking up to the door that
is your safety and escape for a second
as you get into the next hallway and
something starts to happen resident evil
safe rooms have the same effect where
you have your moments of safety before
you have to have like the breathing
moment of
okay i have to go out and i have to face
whatever's outside of this door i think
the video game specifically if i don't
have
something that feels safe even if it's a
corner of a room where i don't feel like
i'm going to be attacked
then everything is just climax all the
time and it ends up being so
overwhelming that i don't feel like i'm
ever actually scared in anticipation of
anything
so i think that those those little
moments where you have um
a break uh or something that that
changes horror games for me entirely
like a good one versus versus one that i
find to just be
like chaotic is is the little bits of
safety that's what i think is important
obviously sound design as well i think
um
dead space perfect example
group has been one of the best sound
designs ever in any game yeah i agree
dead space is uh the score that that
launched the
uh the broader recognition of the
composer jason graves
who had been working in games up until
that point um but
that was kind of like the thing that
notched it all up and he won a bunch of
awards and things and
i remember i didn't know him he's since
become one of my closest
friends in the in the world of composers
he's just an amazing guy
but i'd never i'd never met him at that
point i remember when dead space dropped
there was an interview
where he was like yeah we did some
orchestral stuff that was so
sort of like technically like from a
technique standpoint not
technical but technique it was so
advanced
that the only way to do it was to write
it by hand and give it to the orchestra
and just tell the audio director there i
can there will be no mock-ups
uh because this music you can't there's
no sample libraries that do this
yeah and this is too specific and too
advanced basically
and i want to listen to it like what do
you mean well that was the funny thing
is i read that
and like i rolled my eyes and was like
this [ __ ] grandstanding
you know what i'm doing is too
innovative yeah i was like who the [ __ ]
does he think he is i had never heard of
this guy and i'm like some guy doing a
horror game called
graves shows up and is like well what
i'm doing is just
beyond the and then i heard dead space
and i was like [ __ ] i don't know
you could ever mock this up i blew my
mind uh
he he kicked the [ __ ] out of it and have
you ever worked on a horror game austin
um i have um i'm
i there's there's one that i'm i'm i
wish i could
i wish i could talk about that i'm
literally working on now
um but um
i've worked on quite a few horror films
um
in fact there's a director i've worked
with more than any other we've done five
features together and he's primarily a
[ __ ] we our first ever film was called
grace
premiered at the 2009 sundance festival
and two people in the audience fainted
and um it was the 2009
uh sundance um and um
and the funny thing is we did a
screening at usc i went to usc so they
did like this alum
screening thing and we hosted a
screening there and
people accused us in the press uh like
the hollywood reporter and stuff or i
don't remember they specifically said it
but
there was accusations that we staged the
faintings to get notoriety because
sundance is a pretty competitive
environment it wouldn't be the first
time right that someone's
yeah well yeah exactly but we didn't
even know like is horror prevalent
in in at sundance no that's the thing it
it it was pretty
uncommon um and um they they have
one at south by southwest maybe i feel
like i always see that that feels right
yeah fantastic or whatever or what
whatever that right
i remember someone brought a
phantasmagoria once to class and
it just it just did not sit well it
means yeah there's a whole there's a
whole
genre there's a whole like uh world of
genre like horror and and sci-fi kind of
um film festivals and stuff that
specialize in that and because we made
the
we made the rounds through all those but
sundance was the was the kickoff and we
did not know that the phoenix had
happened until the q a
afterward when we're up on stage and a
security guard was like hey just so you
guys know
this happened during your movie
holy [ __ ] yeah somebody died that was
that was sad
i can't wait for your movie man the
funniest thing was that
at the usc screening i i get an email
afterward from some guy who's like hey
i know that you know people because we
talked about the sundance thing at the
usc q
a and mentioned how people had fainted
and this one guy messages afterwards
like hey you can add me to the list and
i'll i'll show you my x-rays to prove it
he had he had he had gone into the
bathroom after the movie he just felt
like [ __ ] i'm this is kind of
getting to me he goes into the bathroom
and he's like splashing some water on
his face and then just wakes up on the
floor
and he had hit his chin uh split open
his chin
going down hit the sink and also had
landed on his
hand weird and had broken a finger and i
went to the park
i broke my knee like two weeks ago
because i fainted and fell on my knee
i fainted exactly that thing i fainted
and i landed on my knee and so now i
have a
fractured patella i think it's called it
is a patella yep
broke my knee so that wasn't because i
watched a scary movie you made
just meaning but similar similar vibe
it's no fun
do you guys remember faces of death was
that a thing
i remember it like going around my uni
yeah i didn't watch it cases of death
was like these
yeah they were like literally snuff film
isn't it
that's the snuff film is made with the
intention of killing the person
um this was just caught on tape like
candid stuff
or um execution
yeah yeah and i think at some point like
like faces of death seven
you're like you're faking that [ __ ] you
know but it was
i remember people like i got a copy of
faces of death it was this this bootleg
underground and there were some video
stores that carried it and some wouldn't
and i i remember watching one and i i
don't know what it is man i just i know
a weak emotional constitution or
something i just i have never
ever been a scary movie guy never been a
gore guy never been a slasher film that
i just
that is not even to this day i don't we
watched evil dead for
for later we did a um uh
every saturday we do a screening of a
movie and we watched evil dead the first
one
evil dead two is a completely different
thing it's like alien versus aliens it's
just a it's a
one is a romp one is as a true you know
horror film
um and even alien i would consider a
horror film right i would i consider
that a failure
oh i for sure consider it a hor it's
like horror suspense like
but i would call a suspense thriller
because it's more
action than it is aliens aliens
yeah aliens is just like that's an
action film but alien is not an
action film no i wouldn't call it an
action maybe i wouldn't call it an
action film you're right it's just for
me for some reason the setting of it
makes it it's it's literally the the
tagline on the poster was
in space that's horror
uh that's yeah at least they were
selling it as horror
interesting i've never considered alien
i could say like there are also a lot of
horror genres there's psychological
horror psychological thriller
two different things like there's a lot
of stuff going on here that it's it's
difficult to identify things and i think
like what i tend to like most in films
is uh
usually a horror movie that actually for
some reason explores families
that's like a sub genre that i find very
interesting is like
stuff like people dealing with guilt
people dealing with relationships
and that's how it manifests itself like
i've done two
three like resident evil six isn't a
[ __ ] it's a survival horror i guess
that's actually that's super action
that's the aliens kind of
version right um but i've done silent
remake
silent hill um the medium is horror
right
and the medium is horror the medium is
my like i can get behind it because it's
it again it's psychological
there's a supernatural element to it
that's super cool
and the mechanics of it are i think are
really um innovative and
and yeah it's gonna be great we're
actually doing something really cool for
today that i can't talk about yet it's
awesome
i think um you're wearing the costume
that is why i wear the costume this is
just a matter of convenience
i think um
so i guess we'll go back to you austin
like what what is it like then scoring a
horror film like how different is that
to
anything else that you work on are there
different instruments is it different
pacing like what is the the how
different is the process of that from
anything else
well all all genres bring like baggage
and cliches to the table so
horror is one of those that's especially
fraught with
that there's a lot of gestures and
cliches and
and um so the goal is always to try to
um
sidestep those as much as you can you
know and grace was
was definitely um one where i feel
it was that score actually changed me as
a composer i always
i worked on it for a year straight which
is very unusual for film normally
normally films are very fast turn around
compared to games and you know a month
two months um and um is that sorry is
that the one where you sampled the house
yeah like it was one where i part of it
was that we had no money like it was
very low budget film
and you know a lot of horror is like you
know just kind of
these sorts of very very simple gestures
whenever you reach my piano i could do
that like that's prefer the uh you know
like the wider
horror movie now blank
[Music]
those kinds of
uh i know i know i've peaked but um it
um that yeah so that that film was one
where like the
the the um um
the thing that we like so we tried a few
things
that were really that were really um you
know i was i was very young
and so and the director to his credit
paul solid who's amazing the very first
person i met when i moved to l.a lived
in the apartment above me
and i met him day one of moving here and
um
and so he this was his first feature he
was working previous to that as a writer
and producer
at mtv on on a celebrity death match
and um doing the claymation a related
field
yeah exactly it's the classic career of
trajectory
yeah exactly yeah he was he was looking
for his out his exit there
and um um but um
he did get me a job though scoring the
trailer when they brought the show back
after a long hiatus i got to score the
launch
trailer uh and uh at the time it was
like
it was like you know i i've done it
uh this is actually going to be seen by
people uh
and after thousands of student films and
things that are never seen by anyone
gratefully but in any case with grace uh
the first experiment that we tried which
was really
cool because paul's mo was the only rule
is there are no rules you know he was
just
he was trying to break convention in all
directions like one of the things that's
really cool i won't say any spoilers
about the film
because i think it's a genuinely
fantastic film and well worth watching
but
one of the things that's so cool is
there's no antagonist in the movie at
all um everybody has defensible goals
it at genuine odds with each other um
well isn't it by proxy then they're all
antagonists to each other if
i would argue they're all protagonists
with competing agendas
um uh like there's no one that you look
at and you're like like there are
they're movies of course full of things
you're like okay that's [ __ ] creepy
like i'm not friends with that person
but they aren't they're not
ever doing things that are actually
wrong and when you understand their
motivations you go yeah you know i may
if i were them i'd probably
feel similarly side question is that the
well i'm sorry go ahead
i was just going to say to be
antagonistic you have to
intentionally be trying to work to
against someone rather than just working
towards your own [ __ ] at odds with them
right like antagonistic is intentionally
working against someone not just trying
to accomplish your own [ __ ]
literary definition i'm not sure because
i've
i've always i love that mike bill yes
yes now
[Laughter]
i'm thinking this is if you if someone
wanted to sarcastically impersonate this
podcast
this conversation this is the perfect
but what does antagonian quintessential
what what
is a protagonist i can smell everyone's
farts from where i
am the i know what i was saying is that
i i believe that there's a clear
distinction
in any medium between a villain and an
antagonist
right so i would say a lot of your debt
for me
your definition someone who is
intentionally being a force of
opposition
would kind of qualify intentionally yeah
would qualify as a villain
whereas an antagonist to me is far more
compelling
because it is i there is the yen yet
there is the yang there is
the equal and opposing force that by the
sheer nature of
being is an antagonist it's it's not
a sense of will but that's why i love
the premise of this movie it's like
is there an antagonist or is there a
villain last of us there is no villain
you can even look at david
and say he's simply just an antagonist
he's not a villain though
yeah i think definition is please a
person who actively opposes or is
hostile to someone or something an
adversary
so i think so it's very relative it is
yeah about being against someone
well well for per just for clarity
because in the end
it's all for it it it's uh
all i mean is that there's no one who
you might objectively say is
the villain yeah yeah um yeah it's
it's it's because they they don't they
don't
nobody's like out to get someone i i
really am being deliberately vague it
would be very obvious if i just
explained but it's a movie that's best
experienced for if anyone
uh listening checks it out like it's a
movie that it's great to just not know
anything about
um it sounds like a bit like reservoir
dogs in that like you're kind of
understanding where everyone's coming
from
yeah yeah it's otherwise nothing like
reservoir dogs but yes
[Laughter]
probably i'm guessing um it's actually
funny enough it's actually very
there's almost no gore in the movie also
that's the funny thing
it's it's very very it i always i
referred to it as a
uh i called it a termite movie and what
i meant by that was
it's like imagine you're in an old
rickety house
where the floorboards have been eaten
away by like thousands of termites
gradually and you don't detect anything
wrong until with no warning you fall
through the floor
that's how that that's how that but yet
the but yet the
the work had been done to make that
possible so it wasn't
random you just didn't see the the moves
being done to
to set up that fall that's how that
movie i felt
worked is it it doesn't it does a lot of
sleight of hand
to just unnerve you gradually um
but um it's not it's not terribly
obvious at least it never felt that way
back to the question austin yes how to
score horror
please stick to the topic sir yeah paula
apollo yeah um
in the case of that one um
[Music]
there were a few things that we tried so
uh first off
while they were because the director was
an old friend i was able to read every
draft of the script over the course of
like three years before
they actually shot it and so the idea
and give feedback and talk about it and
so i knew
i knew the film extreme he was basically
the only person who knew the film better
than me by the time they went to go
shoot
so i had this idea where i said what if
i write a score
based purely on the script that's very
exaggerated emotionally
from anything you would want to do but
is trying to approximate the internal
emotional turmoil of
certain characters the idea being what
if while your cast are in hair and
makeup and stuff
they can sit there listening to like
this
fully throttled version of where their
character is
at and then they can you know it's a
tool to to kind of get them in
in the place and even play it back for
the crew and then in a
in a fantasy world they kind of
internalize that
emotion to such an extreme degree that
they wear it in their performance
and then we put no music in the actual
finished
film um like the idea is thick approach
to scoring
it's it's homeopathic it's
how how how nothing ever in there
we take we take a score and we one drop
of diluted
in five actors and then we dilute those
five actors
yeah i can see that well kind of funny
enough um and
um it was it was a fun experiment but it
also let me try out a lot of those
cliches of like slashing violins and
whatever
and then it's like okay now let's do
none of that and partly because we just
really
literally had no money i i am i i
exhausted 100
burn my whole savings account going over
budget
um and was literally living with zero
safety net for like five years
wow um because of that film and
i regret nothing though because we did
do a session at abbey road uh with all
clarinets
uh that was part of the score um of
course you did
basically it was an 88-piece bassoon
section
eight eight uh eight contrabass
clarinets which are the
really like the ones that played down in
the very very very bottom
and um and um the um
the rest of the score the the one thing
is the one little piece of information
i'll offer about the score about the
movie
is that it revolves around a woman who
has a newborn child
and so instantly creepy i uh it's not a
rosemary's baby movie
at all though uh i don't believe you
it's not it's not it's but there but a
baby does figure into it so what i did
so
the baby is the guy but anyways
nope nope i won't i won't yield on that
but it's more of a
antagonist than the villain funny enough
the director
anti-christ in the sense of the director
was always
obsessed with that the baby is a
beautiful beautiful baby
but anyway baby was it a real baby yeah
they had a real baby so here's what
if like how does that work if a baby's
in a film
uh well
there's a lot of people who have um i
don't necessarily know
obviously babies can't but that's why
you always see twins
uh the parents are the legal guardian
therefore are not only responsible for
the baby they must
sign a contract for the baby they are
the ones who make the money that is
where you get a lot of these
child actors who have made nothing
and their parents it's not good
but i thought that there was a i thought
there was a sag
practice of like
there's an account that the kids don't
necessarily have access to until they're
18 but the production is knowingly
paying into an account that
that's not that is theirs that would be
a trust
and that would be have to be elected to
be created
yeah the sag cannot create a trust for
you no the sag wouldn't have created it
but i thought that was a rule that you
basically had
i i'm obviously totally out of my depth
on this
one but i thought i had heard that
before my question
did you play the baby the scary music as
well
yeah i did not play i did not not but
here
i would expect a therapy bill in about
18. exactly
here's the austin wintry right go [ __ ]
yourself
austin's like this is going to create a
performance
i wish i thought of that actually to be
honest but uh no here was here's what we
did i had an engineer
that i was working with um who
had he had a a newborn right around the
time
that they were um like getting ready to
film get start the movie so i gave him
one of these in fact i may have even
given him this very one a little
portable
zoom recorder and i said for the next
two months
anytime your baby's crying or making
other weird inhuman noises
can i can you record it for me and
um because he literally had like a one
week old baby at that point
and so then like two months later i get
this thing that has you know the
little sd card is just loaded with hours
and hours worth of
of uh sounds and what the hilarious
thing is
like he's an engineer you know he's
worked staff at
fox for a million years his father is
tommy tedesco is one of the most
legendary guitarists in all
of studio history played with like the
beach boys and
and you know endless legacy there
um and um and so the the the son damon
he comes back with this uh recording
where
i'll hear like muffled baby crying and
then it like
does the thing where it's like and you
hear it open up where he's like clearly
moved into a better position
and then there's like in a protracted
period of crying and then i hear like
and then wife comes in what the [ __ ] are
you doing change the [ __ ] child
and he's like wait wait wait i just need
10 more seconds and he's like he was
very committed i had all this marital
argument
b-roll in my uh in my audio as well
but the idea was because if you look at
spectral analysis of human hearing
we hear from about go on egon we i was
going to say come on
um we hear from about 20 hertz to
very faintly up to about 20 000 hertz
right uh
and anything above 20 000 that's like a
dog whistle it's just completely
imperceptible to us
even even above like 15 000 is almost
inaudible to us
um and most people have women hear more
by the way
they hear more like higher higher
definitely true
women women have a higher uh men are
more narrow it's actually closer like
15 to 20 hertz from or uh 30 hertz i
think for men
and they hear whiter which is why i
think why
women are uh that's a maternal instinct
it's it's being able to hear better like
well
that's where that's what i'm doing with
this actually is that
um that disparity notwithstanding in
general we have a pretty even
distribution
of our sensitivity to that full spectral
spectrum that frequency spectrum but
in the like i'm blanking now on what
frequency is but
we'll say like maybe 500 or so
all human beings have a spike in
sensitivity where we can hear
that there's a very specific spot in
that range where we hear with
really elevated sensitivity and
unsurprisingly that's exactly where
babies
cries fall wow and it and it's in a
perfect demonstration of that that
everybody has experienced is being on a
plane
and you're shouting to talk to the
person next to you and 20 rows back the
baby sounds like it's in your head
no way and there's also something i feel
really
interesting about that as well i think
that's completely a response from that's
an evolutionary
thing exactly like a raging storm or you
know
flash flood you got to be able to hear
with the other night
i it was night before last i was awake
from like
2 30 from my dentist appointment
and then um i also it's
like half past two to five and i was
awake
and traveler was awake too and we've got
the little ipad asleep that
sleeps between us that's that's between
pam and i so that we can hear travelers
it's turning into a black mirror
yes um but traveler wasn't there
um i and i i'm at the point now where if
if
um the the the the
baby monitor that we use is wi-fi and so
it was like cutting out and stuff and so
it was i was
super aware of when he was sleeping and
when he wasn't
and and like he was just like if he
makes a sound i i wake up
uh which is super cool i love that
because i've always been a dead sleeper
and i was always afraid that i wouldn't
be able to respond to that
it's cool that that's a that's baked
into our genetics
you know going back millions of years
that
evolutionist has said this thing needs
to happen in order to
to create you know continue the species
the other thing that i found really
interesting
as far as like frequency and sound is
someone told me
that um they're you go they have
subsonic and ultrasonic so subsonic
obviously is below that
frequency that we can that is human
perception and ultrasonic being above
there is a note that is subsonic um
that is is called the god note
and it is a resonant
that's where that's the brown note the
the god note is
um this note that if played
um can evoke a sense of awe or wonder
and the way that a basilica-style church
is laid out is
is always in the shape of a cross and if
you walk in
a whisper has to go somewhere so that
sound even though it's super super
small travels back to the back of that
building a long narrow corridor
reflects back off that back wall and
comes back to you which is also a flat
surface and so because there's
there are two parallel surfaces it
creates what's called a standing wave
and then as it does that it just gets
louder and louder and louder and louder
but it's inaudible it's too low for us
to be able to hear it
so that frequency is like 10 hertz
actually
when we walk in if we were able to hear
that it would be like going to a metal
concert it's
so loud and so that's why when you walk
into a church
you feel this sense of people talk about
i can feel the presence
quote presence of god here and that's
what it is
that to me is scientifically god
resonates with 10 hertz
right god resonates with 10 hertz my
thing is this i understand
why like you can look at this and say oh
this makes sense that at 500 hertz all
humans are have a
higher sensitivity to hearing why is
that the response that our body has
at 10 hertz
i i i would have to read up more on this
one to to offer anything other than just
random guesses sure it would be
interesting though right guess would be
that you are perceiving something but
you can't place what you're perceiving
because you can't actually
hear it so you you can feel it
potentially but cannot actually audibly
hear it and thus
you are aware that it's there but you
don't know what you're missing and so
that's
the analog to that societally the the
structure of that is well that's what we
call god
right the the unseen invisible forces
we have naturally as a society have
ascribed to
quote that's that's basically what i was
going to say is that it's really
difficult to disentangle what would be
culturally
right taught and then projected onto a
phenomenon
versus like if because if you went and
found someone that's never heard
any religious belief whatsoever in their
whole life and exposed them to a
phenomena the real test would be if they
came to the same conclusion
but that that's happened like the people
that you know you go to
the the the cliche is always like the
the completely isolated tribes
this is what i find fascinating about it
believe it or not this ties back into
horror
you go to the most isolated tribes that
have never been caught
that have always been cut off by modern
civilization that have never seen
something or someone outside of their
ecosystem they live in a complete and
total bubble like missionaries go down
there and they've never seen
another human before other than their
their own tribe
and they will find that they have
created the same systems that we do one
of democracy
or or totalitarianism or a sense of
religion
a a commerce system like these things
exist and i that's what it's like but
very
diversely i mean that's very diversely
but the fact that there's even still
that
shows that they're a part of our social
evolution like we we do that out of a
response
it's just it's interesting to me i
wonder why
we still have these notions of or these
these
genres of horror whereas by and large we
have
as a species try to escape you know
danger
and fear and and all of these things but
we then we rush towards
why do we do that why do we as a species
still love
to watch scary movies think it's because
it's controlled fear
so i i agree you know someone who enjoys
horror i feel like i
i like it because i have control i
i because it makes you feel like the
fear that you feel over anything else
has less power i think when you get to
experience it in a controlled
environment where
you know that nothing bad is going to
happen to you it's a controlled
experiment yeah
gotcha yeah it's a way to like sample
uh it's like it's like
getting super high with your friends
where you're like
we've put away our keys we've got a
glass of water there
it's like a way to a way to have a very
safe
that's that's like psilocybin that's not
that's not even getting high like you if
you're like
setting yourself up that way the only
thing that if i get high i need to know
from people
is like hey i'm not the only one right
like we all did this because that's the
worst feeling is like you always feel
like everyone else opted out and you're
the only one that opted in
and it's like that's the worst that's
when they always tell you troy that was
just water man that's the worst
that's what's the worst exactly
you're not even here now i'll ask you
next mike have you worked on any
horror games never works for me horror i
don't think i have actually
i don't think i ever have um i'm not big
thomas was alone
thomas was alone thomas was alone that's
just that's
a that's a horror movie but he wasn't
necessarily scared about it
he wasn't he was pretty chill about it
mostly just loved falling
yeah yeah um no i think and other shapes
i was saying this i was talking to um
kerry about this yesterday because we
were watching we watched um the shining
and dr sleep
two nights in a row what's dr sleep i
don't know if you don't understand that
mike flanagan uh sequel
yes sequel to the shrine we've been
watching his uh
netflix haunting of hill house finally
um
i think i think i think for me i need
high concept for me i need horror plus
something else that's when i enjoy
movies so i like horror i like horror
when it's
funny or i like horror when it has a
political message or like horror when
it's
clever story-wise i like for me horrors
like
it's i i would never sit down and just
watch like a generic horror for me i
always need the
the twist on a genre horror like you
know cabinets
but the reason i like get out is not it
doesn't scare me i'm not
right yeah to me i wouldn't even call it
it's more of a it feels more like a
drama yeah again we're just throwing
that's how [ __ ] the genre is off a
horror you're just like sort of a
psychological drama
uh political uh like saw like like hor
like horror murder or whatever i love
saw because it's a really good bottle
episode i love saul because it's just a
really interesting i think saul one is a
fantastic
film the first one is incredible the
first one ever once it became a
thing then it was like uh [ __ ] you
that's that's where
and i and i was i was dragged to say
that i was like i have no desire to see
people get tortured that's just not
that's not well you understand it's the
machinations of it i was like okay
but um for me the shining
as as as good as it is i feel like
um the make it's almost like heart of
darkness the making of it is more
interesting to me than
the the movie like what stanley kubrick
was doing and the contention between he
and stephen king
where he was like [ __ ] your book man i'm
gonna make my movie and all of the
little small things that he put in there
uh there's a great one room 237 if uh if
you've never seen that documentary is
interesting it's a bit conjecture but
it's also really really cool
um i'm i'm with mike i like something
let's go back to it because i love
fabric films generally literally my
favorite director however
yeah kubrick yeah he's not on a human
level but
yeah i was going to say what i'm going
to say he's a piece of [ __ ] like what he
does is
is awful and i've always found that
conflicting with the shining especially
because
he is treating people terribly in order
to get
the opponent just watching it yeah so
was it
the first time a couple of days ago and
i genuinely felt uncomfortable watching
it felt like i was watching
actors being bullied it felt like
especially
especially um the wife i don't remember
the name of the character like she seems
genuinely in distress
yeah maybe she's an incredible actor no
no no no no he did awful [ __ ] to her he
he prevented the crew from being allowed
to talk to her so that she felt
completely isolated nobody was allowed
to be nice to her
like she was treated terribly to have
that incredible performance and i'm
always like i don't know how i feel
about this like it's
so exciting honestly that makes him a
terrible director
it's it's the same thing as like when um
what if she was just a horrible actor
and it was his destiny and don't get it
makes
it still makes him a bad bad director
because he shouldn't have hired her yeah
well i meant that half jokingly but fair
point but it's the same same thing
applies
the the the story of dustin hoffman and
and uh lawrence olivier and marathon man
was running around he's like my dear boy
have you tried acting
it it is what what requires uh i i found
out that um
uh judd nelson was um john cusack was
originally
cast as john bender in the breakfast
club
and john hughes was like i really think
that hold on
hey dude oh my gosh
what do you think of this who am i
there's a big moment
a fight there is that is a light
[Laughter]
swinging
[Laughter]
this is horror what is that
i feel a little heartbroken
i was like he will either love it or be
terrified of it or not didn't expect a
difference
yeah he just looked and he was like uh
dad means i hate everybody
i guess dad's an actor wears a lot of
hats yeah
come here say they can't see you so can
you come closer so they can see you
hi
[Laughter]
look at that long look at that hair
trailing behind him
okay good nap buddy i love you bud
that is amazing
adorable cool my kid is so awesome he's
very
um i i uh and with that i actually have
to just wrap this up i apologize
um i believe just just last thing the
horde
the horror stories of directors um
those scenes require trust and it is
a um there's no machinations uh any
director that tries to
talk about john hughes and john cusack
was
the original choice and john nelson
almost got fired from that film because
he was staying quote in character the
entire time
and what makes john he's a great
director is that he quickly
um was able to sideline judd nelson and
go hey man that's not going to work this
is about two peop
this group needs to trust each other um
and he empowered those people to trust i
i believe that's what makes a good
director anybody that goes watch this
i'm gonna make this person is now
forcing
that character and doesn't understand
the distinction between the actor and
the character and that's just that's
just terrible
yeah so i i don't yeah kubrick good
i also don't think it's it's also i
don't think a film that i don't i didn't
love the shining i'll be honest which i
know is blast for me like
that's not blasphemy yeah
it made me uncomfortable like the muse
and we talked about sound design like
that high
buzz that's in for about half the movie
was just i was just
on edge well isn't that the intent
though that was the end of course no
yeah no of course yeah no absolutely but
what i'm saying is i guess for me with
horror like i said it has to be
something else it didn't feel
it didn't feel like it was as engaged in
its themes as just trying to make me
uncomfortable so i didn't
love it yeah i agree with that have i
told you my awesome ship obviously
how about i'm gonna take that
opportunity to completely mess with
alana's composition sorry and bow
and bow good day yellow safari man it
was nice having you yellow safari
man i'm troy baker and i will speak to
the acting
yes i do want to make sure that
with everything we've talked about with
with horror and
bad directors and everything that um
more than anything you guys remember
that
i was wondering it's it's funny because
it's consistent
he does that joke i feel like twice a
month it's amazing
son of a [ __ ] um so mike you've
your answer was you've not worked on a
horror game but i guess like other any
uh tropes you recognize in horror games
or things that you would do or things
that you like
because like again mine is the the piece
of safety that's true it's really
important to me
like the thing that i find fascinating
about horror games just in general is
that
so much of game design is about serving
the player and horror needs you to
actively work against the player or or
work against their comfort in order to
entertain them right like
so that's the thing that's fascinating
to me when i look at a lot of horror
games
they break the rules quote unquote of
like
oh we've got to empower the player we
won't give the player what they need in
this moment like
horror kind of it's almost anti-design
it's intentionally
making your life harder it's giving you
less things than you need it's messing
you around
i don't know if i could do it i think i
would really struggle with that as a
challenge because to do that but to make
it interesting and entertaining
that's i have so much respect for people
who do that it's amazing
it's true oh i was just gonna say it's
true because like you know when i think
about resident evil
because i love that series like
especially like two and four
particularly i really liked seven as
well actually um
it they they they keep you going
through something that is oftentimes
very uncomfortable or grueling
but that i think the puzzles in resident
evil are the part where you feel
smart where you feel satisfied where you
feel a sense of accomplishment which
would be
its version of player empowerment is
having
like smartly designed puzzles that
actually make you think and engage
whereas
if you took the puzzles out of resident
evil
i don't even really know if i'm sure
people would still be compelled to play
because people love horror games um like
i still like layers of fear and layers
of fear does have safety rooms like
laserfield one and two there are moments
of safety
but for the most part the thing about
layers of fear that gets me uh
is obviously bluebird team who will also
make the medium um
anytime you turn around the thing you
thought was behind you is not behind you
anymore
so you constantly just have this this
shifting but that does the same thing as
like
i know i'm never safe unless i'm in this
like one very specific area but the
puzzles
have to keep me going because i'm
repeatedly engaging
in trying to accomplish the thing i
think if you remove the puzzles from a
lot of those games i'd just be like
what's what's
i'm just terrified what's the point so
actually that's my i want to flip that
back to you then
because i think that's an interesting
kind of angle on this what makes a bad
horror game well
as someone who's a fan of the genre what
is it is it things like that it's things
like what what is it that you play a
horror game you're like ah that wasn't
for me what is it that jumps out as
what's bad design in horror games i
think uh
the biggest thing that breaks a horror
game for me and i had this experience
with alien isolation which is probably
one of my least popular
opinions is uh bad ai if i understand
the ai too well of whatever it is that
i'm
fighting against um
or it's too easy to manipulate or just i
guess not smart enough then generally
i'm going to find something
illusion disappears i think because i
love that game a lot of people do and
and it like for the first like
maybe six hours i was terrified um but
then there are parts where the
xenomorphs are literally on a loop
and as soon as that started happening i
was like like these parts now just feel
tedious to me
because i'm like you're not scaring me
when i know that your ai isn't actually
focused on
what noises i'm making or whatever else
where i i consistently found
the um what are they called the robots
um the working joes yeah i consistently
found them to be terrifying
but the xenomorphs lost me at a certain
point to again the extent that
yes i never observed that because the
thing that blew me away about that game
was that they did they managed to make a
20-hour game where the xenos
never felt like
a tolerable risk you know what i mean
like you know at some point in a lot of
games
yeah like you never you never get the
sufficiently large
gun where you can just knock them off
you know like a lot of games do that
once you reach a certain threshold
yeah you're just so powerful
but that was the beauty of that was that
that just they kept their distance and
so when you were facing them
they would keep out of range and then
just walk slowly with you and i was like
[ __ ]
it to me it was just as terrifying and
and and the act of having to run to the
save points
yeah um it was like in jurassic park
when they're in the kitchen
and they try to run for the freezer you
know they're like okay we they're gonna
see us but we hopefully just get there
in time
like that that's how every save point in
that game felt to me i just
see it and i'd go i'm probably gonna
hear them chasing me and i'm just gonna
just gonna make it go yeah assessing the
risk and like i i do really
i do really like that game but i think
actually like my criticism in relation
to
the ai becoming predictable to me is
also something that only people who play
a lot of video games even seem to notice
and i know that it's broken horror games
for me like
the first evil within the second one
didn't do it but the first evil within
was like
at a certain point pointless to me
because i understood what the level
design was so well
that i could skirt things without being
afraid at all i was just like this map
is
my brain understands exactly what i have
to do thus i can just walk through it
and and know exactly
i just stopped being scared i was like
well this is on this loop etc so it's
just too obvious
alien isolation some people probably
never even notice
like when the ai is on a loop or
whatever but i think my um
my bigger issue is that the game is just
too long so if it had have been a little
bit shorter then i probably wouldn't
have noticed
those things you wouldn't have had time
to learn that pattern or they wouldn't
have felt tedious
because it just happens in like these
specific sections where it's like
i know what its pattern is why is this
happening again whereas the moments
where it doesn't have a pattern
can be absolutely terrifying like again
like i said the first like six hours of
that game are like some of the best
horror i've ever played it's it's the
latter
i mean they also they do like they do
the same as the ridley scott
alien where they don't even bring you
the xeno
until a considerable distance into the
game i got it you know earlier than i've
ever seen anyone else get it
i uh i recorded a let's play for it when
it came out so i was still back in
australia and i
i had got it before you even get on the
first tram
which i guess like no one even sometimes
you just punch your microphone
no one even really knows when it can
first show up but the area that i got it
and i got it i got it really early
i thought it was a very specific i
thought it was a very specific
apparently it's not a bug
i don't think so it just like got me
yeah it killed me inside of it
because i've played through the game i
played through the game a couple of
times and it always showed up at the
the same exact room for the first show
where it showed up for me but yes
it definitely is terrifying to begin
with but that the ai broke it for me and
again the game's a little bit too long
it has
a lot of fake climaxes there are a lot
of moments in that game where you're
like you got to get to this location
oh you fell through the floor oh no this
location oh you fell through the floor
again and i was like stop making me fall
through the floor
so i just started to get like a bit it's
funny how people love that game
yeah i've heard i've heard all those
complaints and for some reason
it all washed over me and i was like i
[ __ ] love this
i i it held my interest for all 20-ish
hours
i played through it more than once i
mean it's i do that very rarely
popular one it's interesting that people
are varied on that but yes they answer
your question mike i think
bad ai and overly obvious level design
um can break a horror game for me where
like evil within
two i didn't have that same read on the
leveled side of the environment so i
wasn't
comfortable especially because it is
alana super quiet to you mike
yeah she is yeah oh that's awesome
you're mike's gone
i started fiddling with my headphones
because i was convinced that i
i broke it but as soon as mike as soon
as mike went mmm
i realized even his little you're like
he can't hear you his little
his little quiet nodding sound was so
much louder than alana's voice
no it's just turned itself down in my
system settings somehow
that's very strange i'm gonna have to
like go to my sound panel to fix that
zoom does that sometimes like if you've
got well i put it through a different
thing
not in uh not in zoom there you are
zoom zoom zoom grabs your system
sometimes i've noticed and like will
actually mess with your system oh volume
yeah
that's right remember when we when i had
those microphone problems a while back
it was that it was zoom was auto
correcting
everything
my uh offering to your uh
question of what makes for good horror
is that
i don't know that i've ever seen a game
really even
attempt this i don't i don't even know
how you would i'm sure
mike you'll this will be the next biffle
short uh
um uh i um but for me the the most
compelling
scary material is when
there is no big bad there is no grand
scheme or super villain sort of
working behind the curtain when there is
just like
this that when when things are
fundamentally irrational
and when things are like that to me
that's the that's the most
uh crafty and great
yeah god evil yeah yeah it well
it's not either there's no agency that's
the point
it's that when when horrible things
happen completely devoid of
any individual mechanism but it's just
like an aggregate
like this is this is the thing that it's
the hardest to swallow
truth about the real world is that a lot
of times really bad things happen
because a lot of individual choices add
up to a bad thing like
a whole society will make a bunch of
choices that are individually not bad
but they just kind of aggregate in a way
that then starts to tilt a certain
direction
and you end up with you end up you end
up with something
you end up with something that's
potentially very scary
but there was no and everybody wants to
say oh who's responsible and it's like
no one yeah there was no way to have
prevented this
i mean i mean actually corona virus is a
perfect
is a perfect uh analog in many ways
because
because even the most aggressively
precautionary
um uh strategies don't
nothing takes things down to zero it's
basically impossible
to just 100 percent eradicate a thing
and that's scary
the thing that gets me about that though
is and this is also a side note
if everyone just collectively agreed to
stay indoors for two weeks
almost literally in time literally
impossible it is but if
if we all just stayed indoors humanity
just everyone for a moment it would be
done
we could solve that in global warming
within like two weeks
just one hit but it can't be done people
people need to survive like it's but
it's just gonna say yeah they think
about that the the the side effect
of that would be tremendous like yeah i
mean like the the
amount of starvation and and just like
secondary horror effects anyone getting
sick in that period of time from
something unrelated that can't call an
ambulance or like the million other
things but
implying there are no easy solutions to
massive problems austin
sometimes i i don't know that i'm ready
to say that that's a big leap
um i didn't even by the way i didn't
even i
i realized i i in my oh
over overly long-winded answer to your
question i never actually finished my
story about
the baby crying uh
and i i i just randomly thought of it
and i will finish that story just to say
that
in the effort to avoid the cliches of
horror music what we did is i took all
those baby cryings and i processed it
into sounds where you couldn't quite
tell what that was
but you still have it falls in this
range that you're very vulnerable
and susceptible to in some scenes
there'd be long scenes where all i've
done is added an almost imperceptibly
quiet sound of a
very distorted sound of a baby crying
wow and that would be the whole cue that
would be the whole
i'd never written you feel an awkward
and uncomfortable
exactly and and and feel like
something's wrong and needs to be fixed
uh you know we have a very we have a
very hardwired response to the sound of
a baby crying
that like there's a there's you know
it's like there's an open valve we have
to solve
this so do you consider that to be part
of the score
it blurs the line i mean it is destroyed
but yeah it was one of those where i
yeah the the the sound if you listen to
the score on its own it's not exactly
toonful listening yeah because like you
could make a case for that being sound
design which is a different
thing um in fact the very funny thing
was that there was a sound designer on
the film who the director didn't get
along with and he
kept adding like very over-the-top
horror like
kind of sounds on on everything creaking
games and stuff
yeah the director just kept telling him
to defer to me basically and saying like
just just like don't don't yeah like let
the score do all the work
uh but but but you if you watch the
movie you'll probably assume a lot of it
maybe is the sound
i also did another experiment which was
fun where i had the actress come into my
studio
and there's a scene where she's trying
to like keep her composure and she keeps
saying words like you know it'll be fine
don't worry about it
but she's she's putting up a front she's
actually freaking out in her head so i
had her come into my studio
and scream those words at the top of her
lungs and then i
added it in sync with but much behind
and below
her actual line in the movie so it's
almost like
a reverb effect on her on set delivery
but then you hear this like
screaming subconscious version sort of
tucked in there
and uh that ended up being really cool
too because you you kind of hear this
echo of the voice but you can't really
tell what it is but it's
super loaded with like anxiety and and
drama and i'd never done any of these
things before that's why i said it
really changed me as a composer it's
really cool
i i did a bunch of stuff of like how can
i make things that are not traditionally
music into music
anyway i don't want to make this all
about me but it was fascinating it was
an amazing experience
i have like virtually no comments on you
know making horror i've never
tried but i've i've been on sets where
horror has been conducted and pretty
much every single time
like the set experience of something is
just not scary at all and it's so funny
like
nothing's scary even in the slightest
and then you see the finished product
and you're like oh [ __ ] that's
creepy as hell but you just don't
realize when you're actually
in the process of making those things
not only is that true
i so i visited the set in canada when
they shot this movie that i'm talking
about grace and there was one really
funny moment
where um a um
uh they had an outdoor shot of this
woman arriving at a house and she goes
to knock on the door
and it's the you know like she knocks
and discovers the doors unlocked because
it gives when she knocks on it and then
she kind of
uses that as justification to explore
into the house and so they were just
shooting this little insert shot of
the knock on the door and it was at
night it was really windy and so there
was this one moment where she goes to
knock and the wind pushed the door open
right ahead of her fist and it was like
one of those movie magic moments but the
hilarious thing is that shot's not in
the film because it looks
contrived it looks like this couldn't
possibly have happened organically even
though it 100 did
wow and uh it was like it made it less
scary because it was like
oh okay you know magic even though
yeah like because it's especially since
it's not like a ghost movie where
that kind of thing might be more in in
like on point or on theme
but there's all these wonderful like
there's a scene where there's someone
walking through the house and the
suggestion i made was what if we remove
the sound of their footsteps
um so that they're it almost feels like
they're floating
because you just subconsciously you're
so used to the that sound
of them walking and especially because
it's utterly silent otherwise
the removal of sound is an interesting
idea where horror is concerned as well
like that is
the absence of sound can be terrifying
where you expect to sound
to occur for sure that's different just
a different kind of unsettling it's like
i just think sound design is such an
important part of horror especially
games because
you know i'm playing amnesia rebirth and
that
for the first hour is just entirely like
little footsteps of something that you
can't hear it's it's the anticipation
that you get from sound design of
a familiar sound but not knowing what it
is or something threatening is just so
chilling in video games especially i
remember playing the first time i played
gone home i was
thoroughly creeped out for the first
half of that i was going to mention that
it's the best horror game i love going
home and the funny thing is that steve
gainer was like
shocked to get that what i heard from
from a mutual friend was that he was
true
that's what i heard from a friend who
worked on it with him who said that she
was like he was really surprised how
creepy peop
in his mind it's definitely not like
there's a couple little red herrings
that are but in his mind they were fun
they weren't like
genuinely cr i'm sorry i was super
creeped out when i first played it i i
get off
to see these are fun and just see what
he was gonna say it's surprising steve
is a very very kind of
conscious designer i'd be shocked if he
if he's doing that by accident that she
genuinely amazes me like
it's my charitable interpretation
of the comment was maybe the degree to
which people found it creepy exceeded
his expectations
that's probably more because you're
right he is a very very
clever and like not at all clueless
about how things could be absorbed
yeah um and uh because but yeah that was
one where
the game i was shocked at how affecting
it was considering how [ __ ] creepy it
was for most of the play through
for sure yeah that that's it's so
unsettling i think a lot of people had
similar experiences with firewatch
where there is something in that game
that's creepy that i apparently
completely missed
i just didn't even see it i think i
definitely
yeah see that's one that's one where to
me it actually felt
they they felt like they leaned into the
creepiness just
maybe once like because it doesn't pay
off
remotely like
i'm not sure quite how hard how to
articulate it feels like they try to
make a little bit more out of the
predisposition that you would be creeped
out
um and because it also ends up not
really being
horror in the way that gone home is also
not horror
yeah it felt a little bit more forced in
the end
maybe i i yeah i just didn't experience
it at all like i didn't find anything
creepy in it because i never found a
thing that other people found i guess
oh just didn't see it um whereas
like i think you saying gone home is not
horror is interesting
you could make a case for gone home
being horror
right like it's not and i agree but you
could make a case that's like
no it's not covering i think you're
still you're still uncovering kind of a
horrific
i think the trick i've gone home is you
assume you're playing something
supernatural
and that's the like it's still a i think
it's a horror but it's
it's it makes you yeah i don't want to
ruin it but like you're definitely
implying one thing and then it's not
that the reality of that story isn't
doesn't have layers of like nasty
unpleasant stuff in there that
you know true emote it just hits you
emotionally rather than
with a jump scare or a shock yeah
there's still some some messed up [ __ ]
going on there but
i think that's a really interesting one
it's like was gone home the first like
very popular walking simulator
i feel like it was the one that sparked
that that you got dear esther would have
been just would have been before
oh i thought it was after esther yeah
i've played the original
i think the original dear esther because
it was originally like a half-life mode
right so i think
oh i didn't know that it was like an
academic uh
dan dan was it was like teaching and it
was like essentially a
school project wasn't it like like like
i didn't know that
i looked that up i'm gonna look that up
i think that's true i think
and it was and and that's also got a
little bit of a horror vibe to it but
again kind of
i guess you don't think of it as a
horror game so much because it's not
like it's not in the dark but dear
esther's creepiest
everybody's gone to the rapture is also
a walking simulator
stupid phrase uh but it is a game where
you walk around a town where everyone's
disappeared
and even though again that would not be
defined as a horror game
i found it so unsettling so incredibly
unsettling to walk around an empty town
where everyone is just gone
and you're trying to figure out why and
you could again it's the unknown so much
yeah i really like that game too
you could i think that's a winning score
ps4
exclusive maybe it's on pc and stuff now
i don't know maybe it was even ps3
it was i think it was curry right
jessica curry yeah dan's wife
uh um and they also did dear esther and
amnesia machine for pigs
oh i didn't know that that same team did
all of those games yeah
the chinese room i didn't realize they'd
done all of them that's crazy huh
yeah they're they're the they're the
husband wife team uh
uh you know she writes all the scores he
does all the design so cool
and um and yeah and their their their
collaboration like that's one of those
where
it's like i i hope to never work with
him uh
because there i and i love what he makes
it's like in some universe i would love
to work with him but that
something really awful would have to
happen that i don't want to happen
to to intervene in that in that
partnership because
yeah they gel off each other so well to
me everybody's gone to the rapture
was a game i remember we were nominated
against each other at the baftas
um i think i think it was assassin's
creed syndicate that was nominated
and um and um i was
like i didn't think i would win it
looked very very much like she would
but i was prepared to be royally pissed
off if she didn't because that
that and i mean that and no like let's
see let's talk about a little
a little game called thomas was alone
and it's music and it's bafta for its
music and who stole that
you know you stole the bafta for that
was it austin i was going to say the
the cocked eyebrows
i think it was i think i think it was
afters it would have been 2013
i think it was 2013 not sure i'm going
to actually go double check that now i
actually don't remember i remember that
i was at my desk
in this spot it doesn't mean much to you
winning that laughter right i was oh i
suppose it was that yeah
well here was the funny thing here was
the funny thing i wasn't able to go
i was i was in this chair recording
violin solos for the leisure suit larry
remake
and uh couldn't have been more opposite
and i had
and gmail was open on my screen behind
me and
and i in my mind it was like let's
finish up
because you know well done and then the
baftas are tonight i'm very excited
journey has a lot of nominations it was
really still like
on this crazy cloud nine of like the
game was just getting nominated
left and right for all these things and
it was just this you know this
sort of fever dream and i remember in my
mind it was like the baptizer tonight
you know
completely ignoring the seven hour time
difference and uh or eight hour time
difference and so i'm sitting here and
the violinist
he's like i feel like you should check
to make sure everything's okay because
he was noticing just like my inbox was
going
because journey had like it won like
seven awards in in succession
yeah um and uh including
including for music i thought that you
found out because that was songs
that was the game awards oh got it or
the yeah yeah it was it was it was like
it was a yeah
i've just checked it was it was it was
david who was up for about two hours
ago everyone it's it's the circle of
life
well with yeah journey got everything
that year i remember being in the
audience because we were up for a few of
the same ones i was like
well yeah i think it was like eight of
them right yeah yeah it was
the funny thing is that it didn't win
it's this year's game of the year the
uh goose game everything it won it won
everything
and then dishonored one game of the year
one game of the year i'll never forget
that
um uh the key thing is journey had no
voice actors so danny got the bafta that
yeah thomas was alone
yeah that reminds me of at my first ever
um game audio network
guild awards which they do at gdc which
is like i may have mentioned
that uh in one of these before but it's
like the composer and sound
design and voice actor community voting
kind of
peer-to-peer um and
and i remember that my first ever one
was 2006 i think when
bioshock um gary shimon won just every
award ever for bioshock but funny enough
god of war three
they have a category of uh best like
because it's like the grammys they get
very they get very um
specific um and so
like there's a category of best
instrumental composition best use of
uh like best um best song like in a pop
song sense and then also best
uh use of choir and i'd never forget
that
the theme to god of war three called the
in begins by a friend of mine gerard
marino won
best use of choir at the gang awards in
2006 and it was like the only
non-bioshock win
and and and i remember gerard gave my
favorite line i've ever heard in an
acceptance speech where he got up and
said i'd just like to thank gary simon
for not using choir in bioshock thank
you very much
and uh it was it was yeah it was just
spectacular yeah it's funny how that
happened certain years like i feel like
last of us part two is probably gonna
sweep a lot of stuff this year
especially now that cyberpunk's been
delayed as well right
discolasim should but it doesn't tend to
do as well at things like like games
like that
was not last year oh yeah it was lost
because it did i think it may have got
nominated for writing
i think it absolutely was nominated for
i think it like i think that was the one
that i was like it should have won that
category and it actually may have even
um but anyway yeah
uh like especially with the cyberpunk
delay i just feel like last of us is
across the board gonna going to do a
great job maybe true
ghost of tsushima i suspect will have a
very strong showing so too
it's definitely those two right now and
like i really love orion and the will of
the wisps and i think doom eternal's a
lot of fun so it's
it's an animal crossing is obviously
hugely successful as well but
it's funny that sometimes you can
predict what games are going to sweep on
what year for sure and i feel like it's
going to be weird with cyberpunk next
year now that's going to be really
strange because it'll be so old
but i guess we'll see what happens uh
that always happens with the grammys too
they're
they're they're um their like window of
time
is very offset compared to the rest so
what happens is
like the nominees will come out and it
will be the things that were it's almost
always very
similarly matched to like the movies
like the score
the the specifically talking about the
soundtrack category at the grammys
is the you know the the release date has
a very different one than the oscars
but it's almost always the same scores
that are or very closely
but it's like like i'm when like that
year that that journey was nominated
the one of the other nominees was that
silent film the artist
um which had won the oscar for score
fully seven months earlier or something
and so it was like wait what yeah that
thing's still around
um and that oh it always it's very rare
that
it happens that it happened to have just
come out at the very beginning
of the uh or i guess it would be at the
very end of the window and therefore
feels like a recent release it almost
always feels like last year's releases
yeah and cyberpunk i think is gonna be
unless the game just turns out to not
somehow be what people are expecting and
just ends up being a total
dud which it would be shocking uh i
suspect it
will be beloved widely it just seems
like
but i wonder if it'll still really stand
a chance when it's going to be so
late at like the next year's nomination
periods of time like where public voting
is concerned if it's out of the public
consciousness they may have just like
lost out on that completely i don't
i don't know um that was that was i was
sure that would happen with journey back
in those days because his journey had
come out in march and you know
it had its little day in the sun march
april
um and so the fact that december january
uh it was i was just like you know yeah
just always expect like if anyone pays
attention at all it's for today
yeah yeah it's true i guess we'll have
to wait and see um but i was going to
wrap up this episode by
just recommending some horror stuff not
that either of these suggestions
are unheard of like both actually quite
well known
um i was actually going to suggest we've
already spoken about everyone play
everybody's caller the rapture
and watch hereditary would be my two
it's like i think hereditary is
one of my favorite movies ever um and i
really love
that particular style of horror um
again like i said very much a family
drop on my list for a while yeah
there's this like 10 minute chunk of
that movie that if you just broke it out
would be the best horror short film
that anyone's ever seen just this little
chunk that's so perfect that is just
so horrific um and gut-wrenching and
such good performances it's it's
incredible um
jody foster just absolutely amazing so
that is yeah official
i think my favorite horror movie i i
adore it so definitely recommend that
and yeah i was
before we even started i was going to
suggest everybody's gone at the rapture
so
check those out for halloween maybe
that'd be cool if you want anyone else
have any suggestions
mike i love the purge series more than i
should i really need to watch those
yeah i've never actually seen them
either yeah really like them because
because they are basically just world
but like they're they're
the first ones so that they're worth
watching in order but like the
the first movie that i had chronological
order of when they were released
they do some jumping around but
definitely watch them in the order they
release because the first one is just a
it's kind of like sore it's a very good
chamber piece
horror movie like fun film but as
they've gone on the world building is
fantastic
they're political right they're super
political yeah
yeah yeah and which i which i know is a
thing i'm i
i like that in my in my in my in my
movies they're definitely films
they're definitely films with an opinion
um but like it's what as it's gone on
that's just
it's it's it's it feeds that part of my
brain that likes knowing all the facts
about the star trek chronology by the
time
by the time you get to like the show's
been running a couple of seasons now
there's like i think it's like four or
five films
and yeah it all kind of builds on top of
each other in a satisfying way
wow you wouldn't expect based on the
trailers because it looks like slasher
trash
it starts as slasher trash and to be
clear like they're always still slasher
trash as well but like yeah
as it goes on it definitely becomes it
is enjoying its
it's steaming it somehow keeps coming up
with original takes on the same i mean
that's kind of a very
cliched idea john wick is in a way
similar that it looks like it
on its face it looks like generic you
know
rescued from the 80s uh action film
and then and then especially the weird
peripheral world building
it really pulls it up above uh well
that's just how that's just because
they're massive nerds
i think the lore in those movies is
great yeah but it's so much fun and the
way they've written it as well with
wic like the way they've built that over
because of the first meeting i took with
them like i went in and i was like okay
how much is a gold coin how much is like
how's this world work and they had no
another audiences because they were like
this is it's stop that here they were
like stop thinking of this as like
a gangster franchise this is mythology
this is
it doesn't it's it's about the gods
fighting and the olympus if you do that
you get it like it doesn't
it's not meant to make sense that's very
cool i like that that makes me
appreciate it even more mythology makes
perfect sense
because like you understand the things
that are happening and that they're
important but you don't know the value
of things it's like but i guess it
doesn't have so much like
mythic symbolism and stuff in there as
well if you like go through like always
pay attention to which statues
characters are stood in front of during
scenes in john wick like there's a lot
going on under the hood there yeah
they're really
they're yeah big nerds that's a weird
because it is
wicked in particular is such a
interesting like
uh chad uh who co-directed the first one
that directed the the two cents like
his no it's such an interesting
encapsulation of like one man's nerdy
interests
because it is basically like he will i
remember like chatting with him and
he'll pull out his phone and
he'll show you a youtube video of like
this is how
this is how this new type of bullet
works underwater and kind of moves in a
really ballistically interesting way
and then he'll also be talking about
he'll just be dropping like yeah
like the classic the greek classics into
conversation stuff it's really
they're very they're very much movies
made by the people who made them derek
and
yeah very cool yeah um austin any
recommendations
my my specialist subject yeah i love it
all right well i'll selfishly uh
encourage folks to check out that that
film grace
i think i want to now paul solid is the
director on prime as well it feels like
private i just checked
your austin wintry fix i know i know i
just checked it is it is on amazon
um streamable uh
and um
game wise i i i i recently played
soma and there's a lot i really liked
about that too
um because what i like is that it
doesn't ever feel like it's trying to go
for
full-on jump scares so it's just like a
film that keeps you on this low heat
for a long time and i was like it's
there's a restraint to that that i don't
a lot of games are like let's go for
just maximum creepiness
um or you know
the over the top that one is also very
unsettling as someone is unsettling it's
the same kind of thing it's just like a
lot of yeah exactly what i love um yep
and um but you also gotta love the
classic um
um do you know um the kiyoshi kurosawa
um horror films um specifically
there's a movie there was one called
cure and one called
pulse and
this is that same director as grace he
got me he was like how much
how much uh korean horror do you know uh
and it's like [ __ ] amazing subgenre
of
film i don't know and um kyoshi kurosawa
is for sure one of
one of the great masters but cure it's
another one of those where again it's
just
it's a movie that doesn't hold your hand
but it's not like black
kind of thing it's one of those where
it's it's like when someone adjusts the
thermostat and after a while you're kind
of the
the frog in the boiling pot where you're
like at some point
aware that you're you're in too deep now
and uh really good those two films
uh are classics hell yeah all right well
that's it from us this week everyone
oh see so excited to take off this itchy
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
classic mike lana baker
michelana baker